this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and in
this week's episode Jonathan is taking
another look at some of the Weaponry
from Rainbow Six Siege so how does this
thing look I'm trying to try hard to
look past the lurid green grid pattern
and whatever the hell's going on with
the butt stock that looks like someone's
stubbed out three enormous cigars on it
no idea what's going on there if there
are any other games gone to mechanics
that you guys want to see Jonathan
breakdown let us know in the comment
section below and for something a little
bit different make sure to check out our
new series Mind Games a show that
explores the psychological impact of
gaming from our relationship with loot
boxes to the psychology behind horror
games right time to check out more of
the guns of Rainbow Six Siege
we've got a nice good view from the side
and well that's not an AK-74 M or
otherwise so why is this not an ak-74m
well let's let's focus on what's right
so the magazine looks about right for
the earlier sort of plum colored mag
5.45 magazine the ammunition looked like
it could well be 5.45 so that's that's
fine the furniture is pseudo Magpul
we've got some sort of optical Mount
sight Mount replacing the rear sight
Leaf which is a real thing that you can
do on AKs rather than putting on the top
cover we've got a absolutely huge akm
style slant compensator on the front
that's what it looks like gas block area
well and the top cover for that matter
akm pattern I had to compare with it
with the remaining one to see if it's
close but I suspect it's a bit of a
fudge because all of that rambling boils
down to this is a sort of non-specific
5.45 caliber AK it doesn't have the
classic muzzle break of an k74 the
markings are obviously wrong the
receiver's not the right quite the right
shape it's the wrong top cover for a 74
M and the furniture is not 74m
there's some interesting rejection going
on on this thing I happen to have uh
paused here on what looks dangerously
close to a stoppage because we've got
some very some non-energetic ejection
shall we say and so this case is barely
making it out of the gun in time and of
course if it doesn't do that then the
bolt will trap it the classic sort of
stove pipe Jam is where you have a case
sticking out the action the Bolt's not
gone forward yeah so it's attempt it'll
attempt to pick up the next round but it
won't get it chambered because you've
got the previous one still sticking out
now that obviously hasn't happened
because it's not programmed in to do
that I sometimes pay attention to things
like ejection patterns and that just
stuck out for me and The Recoil is
probably okay it would depend very much
which muzzle device was fitted and this
appears to just be a generic bird cage
type flash suppressor which wouldn't
really have any effect on recoil
mitigation the traditional AK-74 muzzle
break is very effective this is behaving
more like it's got that on it
foreign
I don't remember the AMT Auto mag being
in this game because that's what this is
here is the AMT Auto mag I can barely
see over it it's huge so this is the the
44 amp model 180 there are different
models but I do believe this is the one
that's being represented here in Siege
and you can see I think that they have
done
really quite a good job it's a very
distinctive looking pistol they could
have taken the Modern Warfare route and
made it look legally different or just
different for artistic reasons but they
haven't they have pretty Faithfully
represented the gun should they have
bothered well me as a tactical shooter
fan no I don't think they should have um
I don't think this has any place in a
game like this but that's just me being
an increasingly grumpy old man
foreign
I will say the magazine changes seem a
little bit slick for this this is
essentially a target pistol and it's
really from an era before rapid magazine
changes were a thing really so the the
magazine release is up here you'd need
thumbs like a bat that's that's probably
not even a good analogy but I'm going to
go with it to be able to reach that
button you'd have to really
realistically for a quick Magazine
change use your support hand thumb and
it's recessed quite quite heavily into
this grip as well so you've really got
to get in there and shove that and then
the magazine does not drop free you have
to rip that out take your classic
tactical reload is not so much a thing
on this
thank you
all right that's quite unusual not least
because it has what looks somewhat like
an FN gl40 grenade launcher on the
bottom of it not commonly seen on sniper
rifles or Precision rifles generally
this is very futuristic looking the grip
is quite a weird shape the stock isn't
too unusual for modern Precision rifles
where they have that skeletal look with
various adjustable features on them but
I think again I think that's an original
design too a very heavy barrel with a
large three chambered muzzle break is it
and the 300 in the name I assume refers
to 300 Win Mag not quite sure the
significance of the EXO on the side but
let's have a look
ready for level
so the underbarrel launcher I didn't
notice it had no visible rifling in the
ball is that an oversight or could it be
some sort of non-lethal thing but then I
also thought this is a sniper rifle
you're going to be at potentially 100
100 meters or something away well a coup
coupling lethal and non-lethal on the
same weapon is usually a bad idea and
secondly it's unlikely to have yeah the
range doesn't really match there but I
was edging the right direction because
this thing appears to be for battering
down doors boarded up windows that kind
of thing so you can then engage from
outside I suppose from a sort of SWAT
point of view yeah people think of
precision rifles as being thousand yard
or whatever rifles and they can be but
for law enforcement very very unlikely
you're going to be going out Beyond even
100 meters to be honest with you you
need to be able to positively ID your
target you need to be able to maximize
the chance of hitting them if you do
have to open fire so it's not totally
beyond the Realms possibility that you
would would put some sort of device like
this on the same Weapon It's just highly
unlikely
foreign
okay this is something I'm not at all
familiar with I know the designation
I've seen it before in pictures but this
is a relatively obscure released in the
west Russian pistol design so this this
is I don't know you can stare at it and
try and compare it to various Western
designs but it's kind of its own thing
it is just a pistol at the end of the
day it doesn't do anything particularly
special I'm sure the designers would
disagree with me there seeing it in use
there it's incredibly what some people
call flat shooting which doesn't refer
to the trajectory of the bullet that
what they mean is the muzzle stays level
when you shoot and The Recoil is as
straight back as possible now that's a
function of the the caliber the design
of the pistol and more than anything
else the position hold of the shooter
and the wrist and arm strength as well
to be fair but there's some things are
flatter shooting than others and I don't
know if this is a fair representation
but it's extremely flat shooting too
much so I would say but what you
typically see with a hat with a pistol
is you'll get some some muzzle rise but
through a combination of ergonomics and
skill those sites return to level on
each shot but they don't stay Rock Solid
straight the whole time unless you're
shooting something like a 2-2 pistol or
22 pistol really
fast
I have got for you our only select fire
P90 we have a couple that are actually
in police trials and they're identical
and they're semi-auto only this one
goes up to 11 or rather to automatic
it's not labeled automatic interestingly
but it does in fact go there so how does
this thing look well I'm trying to hard
to try hard to look past the the lurid
green grid pattern and whatever the
hell's going on with the butt stock that
looks like someone's stubbed out three
enormous cigars on it no idea what's
going on there the magazine looks a bit
melty I don't know if that's a skin or a
mistake but the magazine looks like that
it's quite smooth a little bit of a
textured finish to it for grip yeah it's
a it's a pretty solid effort some of the
angles don't necessarily it's a it's a
bit too flat in various places so this
foregrip here is iconically weird
curved foregrip actually has a sort of
triangle flat to it here and then it
goes full round basic basically in in
the game it's very flat all the way
around this is the level of detail we
have to look at guns with in this job I
suppose what I'm saying is it's a little
bit off but not really so you'd notice
unless you were staring at a real one
like I'm fortunate enough to do
now the Russian weapon we don't yet have
the pkp or passion egg 6p41 without
looking it up will be the Grau index
designation for this weapon which is
another good way to name a weapon in a
game without actually naming it for
whatever reason usually legal
interesting paint Scheme I can't think
that's standard with heavily referencing
the former Soviet Union I think it's a
good without having one to show you
pretty good effort on the pkp which is
as I think we've covered before a sort
of evolution of the PKM and this one is
the Bullpup kit version trigger group is
or is shunted forward and making the
whole thing a lot shorter but keep
preserving the barrel length that's what
a Bullpup is there may or may not be a
book on the subject
hostile activity
friendly last operator standing
well I can't speak from direct
experience on how the pkp handles but
nothing leaps out as particularly weird
if you're going to assault with him with
a machine gun this one makes a lot of
sense got a heck of a lot of punch it's
nice and compact the balance will let
you keep better control of it firing it
whether from the hip or the shoulder not
usually the thing to do with a belt-fed
machine gun but it has been known
although having said that most machine
guns with the intent for this kind of
again assault purpose as it were tends
to be in smaller calibers for better
control
foreign
looks to be an M249 specifically with
that heat shield handguard on the front
just uh looking at the reload there um I
was a little skeptical that they'd I
thought they'd fudge that a little bit
by just
pressing on the mag catch but as you see
there you can in fact just tap it with
the thumb and that's enough to dislodge
it at which point you can just pull it
out so a more positive way to do it
would be to press and pull but the way
it's been done
by the player character is actually fine
so something that crops up quite a bit
with video game weapon design is you're
often working from even if you've had
access to the real thing you're often
working from 2D images maybe just a left
and right a worst case and so you tend
to miss details like this so this this
welded on
um mounting lug on the front here on the
real gun
is actually
not just a solid tube it's a flat it's a
small diameter tube with flanges on it
and the bipod legs actually go Within
those flanges you can see it's sitting
inside
there now why am I going on about that
well these guys have they've got the
weld they've modeled the weld on the
tube really nicely but the actual tube
is solid and there's no way you could
fit a bipod to this even if you had a
hand guard with a cutout to accept it
which they also don't now that's a big
deal because you would not ever use an
lmg or purchase an lmg that did not have
a bipod it's critical to its function
even if you think that you're going to
use it primarily as an assault type
weapon you're still gonna want the bipod
it's not worth getting rid of it
foreign
I don't normally comment too much on
tactics or ttps and stuff because I have
no no practical experience with it and
it's not my direct remit but I couldn't
help but smile at the hanging off the
side of a an uneven wall from some sort
of Mega repelling system that is able to
stay in place but also roll across the
top of the wall and actually a bit
unfair gameplay wise as well you can
basically stay in cover all the way
around the perimeter of the wall and
where it comes back to my relevance is
whilst also shoulder firing a light
machine gun and therefore having no
hands and just using your feet it's it's
very much action movie fair but I've
never even in an action movie you won't
see free traversing repelling while
firing a machine gun I don't think or
not yet anyway you wouldn't be able to
pull that off in real life very easily
even for a stunt
thank you
all right this is another weird one very
strange it looks a lot like a an Ingram
based design now there is an Ingram
derived design from MasterPiece Arms in
the states that looks quite a bit like
this every detail is different but the
fact that the lower looks polymer and
the configuration of it the fact that
it's elongated the arrangement of the
cocking handle not being on top but
being on the side it's all quite
reminiscent of that design but strictly
speaking this is a fictional gun
thank you
we have got some astonishing recoil
there I'm not saying it's unrealistic
because if this thing is 9 mil by 19 and
fires it what sounds like 1000 rounds
plus per minute then it may well be that
difficult to control that said we have
got a foregrip on there and with a bit
of skill I'd expect you to be able to
keep at least start with a burst that
would be on Target on a man-sized Target
or whatever this is whereas this is
wandering all over the shop as soon as
the as soon as Dave pulls the triggered
basically so it seems like they have
programmed in quite a lot of recoil to
make up for the blistering rate of fire
absolutely typical of a video game
compact SMG slash machine pistol to
treat them that way otherwise why would
you use anything else
designed
insert Jurassic Park reference here
because it's the good old smash 12. now
the first thing I noticed about this is
like ours this gun has the rotating
safety this is actually was actually
recalled it was a dangerous design that
if I remember rightly could fire when
you rotated it to fire not ideal for a
safety catch the other thing that I
noticed right away now as far as I know
this fast 12 was never made with an
integral picatinny rail which on this
looks to be part of the forging or the
casting or whatever this is meant to be
in the game the real real gun has
nothing here same goes for the heat
shield now you could easily attach a
particularly picatinny rail to this heat
shield guess that's how you probably
would do it if you were trying to update
this thing with a red dot sight you
wouldn't you'd leave the receiver alone
and you would use the heat shield
otherwise it looks pretty good we've
even got a bit of wear and rust on this
thing so we do get this quite
distinctive wear pattern which is not
quite well represented on the heat
shield from the movement of this grip
because although I suspect in this game
it is semi only this was designed to be
either semi-automatic or pump action
meaning you could load rounds that
wouldn't otherwise have enough energy to
operate the gun like breaching rounds
for example and that's done with a push
button under the pump grip which you
push down pull it back latch it into
place and that has now engaged with the
action bars effectively to turn it into
a pump action not that many shotguns
have that capability and but it's one
that's rarely represented in video games
because what would be the well I say
what would be the point I nearly did
there'd be every point in Siege because
in theory you could switch to breaching
rounds and have to use it as a pump
which means if you breach through the
door and you're left holding a shotgun
suddenly it would be a pump action
slower to operate gun firing less
damaging well arguably against body
armor less damaging rounds so that could
actually have been a gameplay feature
foreign
Ty here well actually it's an oddity in
in the real gun world just as it is in
games I can't recall having seen one
before it is an AR well would you call
it an AR-15 probably not AR pattern
shotgun hence it's massive and chunky it
follows the ergonomics the basic design
architecture of the AR-15 AR-10 series
of rifles but it has a massive thin wall
Barrel a huge magazine well and designed
to take 12 gauge shotgun cartridges but
it will be familiar in terms of
operation to anyone that's used an AR
pattern rifle which is a lot of people
these days quite an interesting
interesting thing to be in this game
um not aware of any serious users that
have adopted them there are too many
reasons I think to use other
self-loading shotguns for that type of
purpose very slick reload there with the
again the the bolt not holding open on
its own which is a surprise and then
flicking the gun back the other way to
send the mag flying out it looks cool is
it worth doing I don't know you best ask
us what team
right guys thank you for watching please
do if you can come and visit us here at
the Royal armories we have three sites
and different different parts of the
country also our social media channels
and our own YouTube channel you can find
me and some more guns from The
Collection over on that as well as some
more interesting stuff coming along soon
that is not guns in any case thanks
again for joining us we'll see you next
week
[Music]
all right